well I'm a huge believer in dumb look I
think done look meets so smart planning
much more often than we would like to
admit people have incorrectly praised my
quite varied career including government
service and public service and I'd like
to explain and how I got into going to
Washington and President Nixon's White
House and later to his cabinet I was
working at 39 south lasalle in Chicago I
used to walk to the railroad stations a
lot cheaper and I one day I noticed at
19 south of cell there was the
university chicago graduate school well
I've been planning to go to Northwestern
where I done my undergraduate work but
it was all the way across Chicago and
since it was night school it would have
taken me 20 30 minutes to get over there
in 20-30 minutes to get back so I said
what you know maybe I had to go to
university chicago is supposed to be a
pretty good place so that's why whence
the universe chicago has nothing to do
with career planning or anything of the
sort it was there that I made some of
the best friends I have on the faculty
Milton Friedman George Stigler George
Shultz and George later you'll recall
became a very senior figure in the Nixon
administration he became secretary labor
office of management and budget
secretary of treasury and then later in
the Reagan administration secretary of
state and George and I had worked very
close together universe Chicago and I
had taught there for about four or five
years part-time at night
so one day he called me and said
President Nixon went see you tomorrow so
I go to wash and I end up in the Oval
Office and the president pointed out to
me that he thought economics was going
to become terribly important at the
vortex and foreign policy and that he
and Henry Kissinger my good friend had a
very complicated relationship for some
reason he felt need to tell me that
Henry didn't know a damn thing about
economics and what was worse he didn't
know what he didn't know so he wanted to
set up a new council counterpart of the
nascar d council and i was to head it
well this isn't anything I had planned
or anything and I'd looked back on that
I've been immensely grateful for my
public service opportunity some of the
most exciting experiences broadening
I've ever had it is led to my being
involved with some great nonprofit
organizations I just stepped down after
22 years as chairman of the Council on
Foreign Relations I'm the founding
chairman of the so-called Peterson
Institute for International Economics
one of the founders of the Concord
Coalition and I doubt very much i would
have done those things if I hadn't gone
to Washington and I doubt I'd gone to
Washington if I hadn't to have him
didn't happen to have an office at 39 s
long just south of cell in Chicago
didn't happen to have a downtown school
at 19 south lasalle so never never
underestimate the role of luck in life
and I think the trick I forgotten who
the councilman was and in New York who
once said I seen my opportunities and I
took them I think it's important
when you do have something that luck
thrusts upon you to somehow be made in
such a way psychologically that as Paul
Tillich said once if you're comfortable
with ambiguity that's that's what you
need when you're in a rapidly changing
world so I say dumb luck and taking it
as your opportunities will often lead to
more interesting places than the
long-term smart career plan